Okay, so in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the Most Holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose
of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother
Mary and in the divine will of God.
And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep and do everything.
May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires, and may you, my beloved
divine will, do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear
from carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure.
And that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will, that you never perceive
even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me.
Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch
my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light, so that I may
understand the truths and the good that are in these writings and prayers, amen.
So I want to take up in April the 9th, 1925, Jesus binds the soul with the thread of his
will.
This is a really lovely message.
Louisa says, "After many days of bitterness and privation, my sweet Jesus transported me
outside of myself, and taking me in his arms, he placed me on his knees."
How beautiful that is, but it's happening in and out of the body experience in ecstasy.
Oh, how happy I felt on the lap of Jesus after so many privations and bitterness.
However, I felt shy without the will to want anything or say anything, and without my usual
familiarity in the past, that is very unusual, which the familiarity she said that I would
normally have when Jesus was with me.
Jesus was doing so many things to me.
He'd last me tightly to himself to the point of making me suffer.
I call that a hard love, you're squeezed to death.
He placed his hand on my mouth.
I think that's absolutely hilarious considering that she's Italian, and it's very difficult
to shut them up.
Almost preventing me from breathing, he then kissed me, and I, nothing, nothing, she said,
I gave him nothing in return.
I didn't feel like doing anything.
His privation had paralyzed me and rendered me lifeless.
Only I let him do what he wanted.
Now, for the 17 volumes that I've been reflecting on with you, you've heard Jesus say over and
over ad nauseam, let me do what I need to do, just surrender, let God be God.
But we find it difficult to let God be God because we like to have control of our lives,
and we do not like to feel that something will happen, that we have no control over.
So this abandonment to the divine will, while it is the thing we all have to do, is also
very challenging for us.
So here she just surrendered to him, I let him do, I did not oppose anything.
Even if he made me die, she said I wouldn't have uttered a word.
So then wanting me to say something, Jesus said, my little daughter, tell me at least,
do you want your Jesus to bind you all over completely?
Okay.
So here you have a kind of a final stage of the divine will taking over because God will
come and possess us, and we will possess him.
This is, she's going to be totally bound in this wonderful relationship.
So Louisa said, do what you like.
And he taking a thread in his hand, made that thread pass around my head, my eyes, my ears,
my mouth, my neck, in some, my whole person down to my feet.
Now you know that with Louisa, Jesus gives her very graphic images of what he's trying
to say.
He's talking to a person who has not got any education.
He is not speaking on a high intellectual level.
So what he does is he lets her experience something and then he explains it bit by bit.
And so this is a way of teaching all the ordinary people on the planet, the high intellectuals
would probably spurn this that there wasn't highfalutin thoughts involved.
But this is for ordinary people and it's really beautiful.
So she's bound from head to foot now.
And then looking at me with penetrating eyes, these are the all seeing eyes of God, Sam 139.
He sees my thoughts before I think, he knows my words before I say them, he knows everything
about me.
So looking at me with those penetrating eyes, he added how beautiful my little daughter
is all bound by me.
Well, we don't usually think we're beautiful when we're all bound.
Now yes, I will love you more, he said, because the thread of my will has left you nothing.
I want you to know to say a word, nothing.
So here you're, that's why I said we're dealing with the final stage here, because anything
you've read about our blessed mother in the divine will, or many of the messages leading
up to here, Jesus keeps on wanting to bring us to the point that we will not concede anything
to our human will.
And while we understand that theoretically, and we probably agree with it theoretically
as well, doing it is a different subject altogether.
So he says, the thread of my will has left you nothing which you might do without the
divine will constituting itself the life of everything in you.
Now this is utterly amazing because this is the possession of God.
This has made you so gracious in the eyes of God as to render you all striking and beautiful
in God's eyes.
So my will has the power of rendering a soul of rare beauty, so striking that no one else
will be able to equal her beauty.
So in the eyes of human beings on this planet, beauty is perceived to be on the outside.
In the eyes of God, beauty is seen from the inside, the condition of the soul.
And now that she has arrived at this point where there's not even one thread left for
herself, in the eyes of God, she has reached a marvelous perfection.
In fact, he says, your beauty is so great and so charming as to draw my eyes, that means
to grab the attention of God, to look at her and to love her.
Okay, so he's going to continue with this revelation.
After he had said this, Louisa said, I found myself inside of myself, so she's back to
herself, or ordinary self, in the bed.
A comfort and strength suggests but also highly embittered, thinking of who knows when he
will come back is the only thing that worries her all the time, when is he coming back.
And that I had told him not even a word about my heart state, hence he had done them out
as well.
So she said, and I want you to really take note of this.
So I began to fuse myself in his holy will, even after this stage where she is now completely
taken up into the divine will, and there's not one space left for her human will, she
still fuses, we need to understand that we have to fuse all the time, all the time, all
the time.
So I began to fuse myself in his most holy will, and my beloved Jesus came out from within
my interior, which of course means that the Kingdom of God is present, Luke 1721 and one
Corinthians 3 16.
Now Jesus came out from her interior, forming a cloud of light around her.
I want to say a few words about this cloud, but I'll read it first.
Jesus leaned his arms on this cloud, now the rest of us know that if you lean anything
on a cloud, it just goes through, because cloud is just vaporized water, if you're talking
about the material thing.
Jesus leaned his arms on this cloud and looked at the whole world from this position.
All creatures became present before his most pure gaze, that's the all-seeing eyes, and
all how many offenses from all classes of people wounded my sweet Jesus, how many plots,
how many deceit and pretenses, okay, so this cloud is somehow a seat or a throne for him.
So I want to take you back a little bit.
When you go back into the Book of Exodus and the redemption of the children of Israel
from Egypt, the Lord accompanied them with a cloud and a pillar of fire.
That cloud throughout the entire scriptures represents the mystery of God.
Right up to the point that when Jesus ascended into heaven, they could see him for a certain
distance and then he disappeared into the mystery of God.
And what the Acts of the Apostles say is he was taken up into the cloud.
So the cloud represents the mystery of the kingdom of God.
What a cloud can mean bad weather or good weather.
This is a cloud of light, so it's an entirely spiritual phenomenon, okay?
And we know since Volume 1, God is light in him, there is no darkness.
We have to be transfigured into light as we go on.
Because we have to be transformed, transfigured.
Dare I say the word trans substantiated into him, he is light.
And so the heaviness of the flesh, all of this has got to give way, give way, give way.
And we only are able to do it bit by bit so that the light takes over and the light takes
over.
And so he has a throne in our hearts and it's a cloud of light because no matter what is
said about it, it is total mystery.
And so it's the mystery of God's presence in us.
And here is Jesus, leaning his arms on this cloud.
So it's from Louisa's heart, it's from her innermost being that he is actually looking
out to the world.
Now he has told her that many, many volumes back.
But only gradually she can take on board the enormity of what he's saying, which is true
for us as well.
On this position of leaning on a person who is living the divine will in so far as the
creature can do it at this particular point, Jesus has a suitable place to live.
Now he's already explained elsewhere that if our blessed mother had not been given the
enormity of the gift of her immaculate conception, God could never, ever, ever have abided in
her womb for nine months.
She would have burnt up.
You'd know that from the experience of the people back in Exodus when God was trying
to teach them about the inevitability of God and the majesty of God and that if they came
too close it was like touching a pillar of fire, you'd just be burnt up.
So the divine will is his throne in us and the more we surrender and abandon ourselves
to the divine will, the more he can actually use us as his presence on the earth.
Now can I tell you that in a way that you should be able to take it on board with excitement?
And that is that God himself would have your address.
He would be living at your address.
I know he is now, but more and more and more he would be ruling the earth from your address.
It's absolutely fantastic because we become his throne.
He was looking out at the world from this throne.
Now he's going to explain to her that because he's looking at the world from a person completely
abandoned to him, therefore that he is moved to be more compassionate with the world.
If he could find no throne on the earth then the earth would experience terrifying justice.
So she sees all of this and she says that all of this drew chastisement.
Now for that bit about all the stuff that she's seeing I want to give you Amos 3-7 because
God never does anything without telling the prophets first.
In other words he actually warms the earth through his friends.
So all of this brought chastisements such that entire cities were destroyed which of
course this is given in 1925 and we know how many cities were destroyed for example just
in the Second World War alone.
My sweet Jesus leaning on that cloud of light Louisa said was shaking his head with an embittered
and was embittered deep into his innermost heart.
And turning to me he told me my daughter look at the state of the world just look at it.
It's so grave that only through this cloud can I actually look at it.
If I wanted to look at it outside of this cloud I would destroy a great part of it.
Now I want to give you two scriptures to look up.
And one of them is Genesis 6 verses 5-6 where Genesis says that when God looked from his
own throne in heaven at the sinfulness of the earth he decided no no we've got to deal
with this.
And in Genesis chapter 11 verses 5-6 again you have the problem of the Tower of Babel
where the people after the human race had revived from the flood they sinned grievously
against God again and God you're told looked down and said if this is where they're at
at this point there's nothing will stop them now we've got to move in.
And so Louisa is being told that because Jesus is looking at the terrible rebellion
of the human race through somebody completely abandoned to him and someone who really loves
him he's not going to destroy it.
But do you know he said what this cloud of light actually is?
He said it's my will operating in you God is light and there's the mystery of the cloud.
I think it's the most beautiful image particularly if you know what the scriptures say about
the cloud all the way through.
It's my will operating in you he said and your acts done in the divine will.
Now the more acts you do in it the larger this cloud of light becomes so we're being
told very clearly that we either give the Lord a very small little stool to sit on and
he can barely get in at all or we give him an elaborate throne because we're doing all
these acts in the divine will that's really up to us.
The more acts you do in it he said the larger this cloud of light becomes and it serves
me as a support how generous he is instead of saying as a throne to make me look at man
with that love with which my will created him so if the Lord is looking out at the rebellion
that's in the world today through us trying to live in his divine will he says here he
will look at them with the love with which he created them look at the mercy we would
draw upon them this informs an enchantment he said from my loving pupils and making
present to me all that I did for love of man it makes a compassionate will arise within
me and causes me to end up sympathizing with the one I so much love.
So we need to look at the great power that is in the divine will mission that we have
and in the divine will prayers that we pray because here we're being told that it touches
the Lord to make him sympathetic with the human race which is a terrible rebellion against
him as for you then Jesus said this cloud of light serves you in a marvelous way it serves
as light for your whole being now if you have light in your whole being that means that
you will see reality as it really is now the millions out in the world who are being deceived
by all the stuff that's actually going on their problem is that they have darkness inside
so they can't see reality as it really is and the wonderful thing about growing in union
with God is that you grow in sight you grow in understanding wisdom understanding council
fortitude knowledge piety and the fear of the Lord the sevenfold manifestation of the
presence of God in us and all the spiritual writers down the centuries have all spoken
about it as enlightenment which is correct.
So it serves as light for your whole being and it places itself around you and renders
the earth extraneous to you now before I go on to that the more we absorb the light into
ourselves that is the God is light the more we draw him into ourselves and the sevenfold
spirit I just want to illustrate it for a second with that incident with Saint Peter
I think it's Acts chapter 4 where Peter and John are brought before the Sanhedrin because
they are preaching the resurrection but they've just healed a cripple and so the accusers
are going on and on and on and miraculously Peter says nothing you realize how much he
has changed and then he gets this inspiration which is really fantastic and you see the light
cuts through all the fluff and all the nonsense that gets through to the reality and Peter
said excuse me we are on trial for an act of kindness to a cripple have farcan ination
fall and he cut out all the nonsense that they were talking about because the light
homes in on the reality okay now Jesus says something else about this light and again
it's a little thermometer so that we know where we're at in this relationship this light renders
the earth extraneous to you let's put on Jordan re-English it protects you from the awful influences
of the earth and it makes you detached from earthly things have you noticed that the more
you go into the divine will the less need you have for everything that everybody says
are must haves you just don't need them because after all if you have the divine will you
have everything you can have in itself and this light allows not one the the Texas taste
and I want to change that to a more correct word desire it allows not one desire however
innocent for people or for things to enter into you oh that's very interesting what's
wrong with the people that you see they see them in the shopping malls and everything
they're craving something I must have if it's a woman it'll be the latest handbag or the
latest pair of shoes or the latest whatever the latest is for the man might be the latest
car or whatever it is but it's I must have I must have I must have and you see the younger
generations grabbing the newer generations of mobile phones and everything if they have
to have the new the new or new and the newest new now all of that means that there's a craving
in their hearts that is not being satisfied and they have to find out that that craving
is for God not for the things they're looking for I'm sure all of us have had the experience
of following an urge like that and you come back from the shop with the new blouse or the
new coach or the new whatever it is and you look at it and say well why did I bring that
home because when you get when you get home you realize that it wasn't the external thing
you needed it was something else something much much deeper and it's this deepest thing
inside of us is this longing for God and so when the divine will takes over it allows
you to hold in on that deepest deepest deepest longing for God and fill it with God and when
you fill it with God then the soul is happy and so the deeper you go into the divine will
the more you find yourself at peace with yourself at peace with God at peace with everybody
around you because you're not running after things craving things anymore so the divine
will doesn't allow you even one desire no matter how innocent for people or for other
things to enter into you now we all have needs that requires other people because we're born
into community and that but it's to enter into you that's the issue there's going to
be no dependence on them our dependence is completely on God and forming a sweet enchantment
also for your pupils we'd say your eyes it allows you to look at things according to
the truth and this is just wonderful stuff it's one of the signs that you will be able
to again use as a thermometer for yourself and that the more we enter into that union
with God the more we see things and people and events and trials and difficulties and
joys and sorrows and life and death and heaven and hell as God sees them you see them as
they are you see them according to the truth and in John's gospel Jesus said only the truth
will set you free so in this relationship you grow in wisdom because wisdom is the first
big stroke of the brush from the Holy Spirit wisdom understanding council and fortitude
so if somebody is claiming to have a deep relationship with God and they don't show wisdom and understanding
I just shake my head the proof isn't there so Jesus said you will see things according
to the truth just as your your Jesus does and so if the divine will number one I love
the way he gives us lists of things every now and then number one if the divine will
sees you weak this cloud closes around you and gives you its strength so when we really
let the divine will in he does everything if it sees you inactive it enters into you
and makes itself the active one even more this cloud is jealous to the highest degree
with its light now I want to stop there even before I finish the sentence one of the things
the scriptures are completely clear about is that God is totally jealous of somebody who
gives themselves to him why he has got seven or eight billion people on the planet how
many people does he have who have surrendered themselves to him if someone surrenders themselves
to him he considers that an incredible gift is being given to him and he doesn't want anything
else to influence that I want to give you a little image that you will understand perfectly
because most of you are married and you will have brought children into the world in bringing
a child into the world you have this extraordinary experience of having been a creator or a co-creator
and seeing a child that's in the image and likeness of God and in the image and likeness
of yourself and instinctively you want to protect this child you want to do everything
for this child you don't want anybody interfering with this you want to teach the child you want
to protect the child you want to heal them you want to feed them you want to clothe them
you want to house them you want to do everything that's God's jealousy for us as soon as we
will give ourselves to him he has been telling us now for seventeen volumes let me do I want
to look after you I want to take care of you so I want to give you just three references
to God's jealousy there are more of course Exodus 20 verse 5 Exodus 34 verse 14 and Deuteronomy
24 24 and all of them refer to the fact that God has succeeded in getting a couple of
million people out from under the greatest potentate of the day they were his people
and he was going to feed them clothe them look after them heal them forgive them bless them
and lead them to their destiny and he brought them to their destiny against all the odds
and so that's this protectiveness of the parent so this cloud of light is jealous to
the highest degree while acting as a sentry to mind you to take care of you so that you
may do nothing without the divine will and it may do nothing without you either this
is the inseparability that you heard so much about between Jesus and his mother and now
we hear it between Jesus and Louisa and he wants to hear it between him and you therefore
my daughter why do you afflict yourself so much allow my my will to work in you and
to concede not one act of life to your human will now that's the bit that we agree with
on paper and we can't even imagine how it'll happen just say to the Lord very simply you're
the one who works project is you're the one who wants the end product I'm the one that
wants you to work in me I cannot bring it about but I ask you Jesus take me from myself
and give me today take me from myself and give me today give me as a gift to yourself
and bring it about you can do it there's nothing impossible with God and so the mistake we
can make is look back on our past and our failures and our struggles and this kind of
stuff I'm only blocking ourselves instead of looking to the Lord and saying look if you
want to do this you're able to do it and I'm delighted so if you want he said my great
designs to be accomplished in you the answer is yes Lord absolutely so April the 15th 1925
the mission of the divine will is eternal Louisa said I write only to obey and to my
great repugnance after a holy priest had read my writings he had let me know that in certain
chapters blessed Jesus was exalting me too much I love Jesus' explanation of this it's
absolutely pure brilliant so the complaint the priest made was that in these writings
Louisa is exalted too much to the point of telling me that Jesus placed me near his celestial
mother so that she would be my model I thought she was the model for all of us never mind
on hearing this Louisa said I felt confused and troubled I remembered that I had written
this only to obey and to my great repugnance and that I was connected to the mission of
making the divine well known and I lamented to my Jesus for having told me this while
I am so bad and he knows all my miseries I want you to notice in case I never said it
before how much time Jesus spends on all her miseries 0.00 and we should just simply throw
ourselves on him and let him just deal with everything and stop letting the so-called
miseries hold you back so Louisa said I felt confused and humiliated and had no peace now
you know from volume one that he is very jealous of us having peace he doesn't want
just to have any disturbance he's been saying that the whole time so I felt such distance
between me and my celestial mother as if there was an abyss of distance between me and her
now when Louisa wants to talk about the summit of sanctity she uses the expression the height
of sanctity it took me a while to break into that particular way of thinking so we say
the summit of a mountain so that the highest point so if our blessed mother is at the highest
point then the I'm down in the abyss that's the great distance she feels so while I was
so troubled my beloved Jesus came out from within my interior of course the kingdom of
God is there and clasping me tightly in his arms to infuse peace into me because he is
the prince of peace and he told me my daughter why do you trouble yourself so much don't
you know that peace is the smile of the soul is not absolutely gorgeous that peace says
an absolutely enormous amount to God the peace is the smile of the soul a happy soul
a soul that knows where it's going a soul that knows it is loved infinitely and it's
loved not because it's great or it's accomplished or it's perfect or anything else it's just
loved loved loved loved because God is love don't you know that peace is the smile of
the soul and it is the Asia and serene sky in which the divine son makes its light blaze
more vividly it's important why has he been insisting all the time on us having this
peace without any disturbance on the inside you can have your hurricanes on the outside
but you must have peace on the inside that's Philippians four seven the piece that passes
all understanding and guards your heart and your mind and they're the two things that have
to be protected your heart and your mind because the thoughts of your mind will actually
express themselves in words and actions so you've got to watch their and the heart all
your feelings and everything that comes out of feelings so it guards the heart and the
mind in Christ Jesus so Jesus says that when his soul has this peace which he calls the
smile and I think it's the smile looking up to heaven he says that draws other souls
are drawn by your peace that's actually terribly important I just stopped there for a second
and just to illustrate that point to make sure that you get it I remember a number of
years ago during an admission I gave in a parish in London and in the afternoon I went
for a walk and I went into an empty church I love an empty church where you just have
the Lord all to yourself and I was kneeling at the back of the church maybe two or three
seats up when I heard a person coming in but I didn't look and the person came over and
sat beside me right up bang against my body to make sure that they were there so I had
to look and it was a woman greatly troubled and she said a number of things to me but
I won't go into the bit I want to just comment on apropos this as she said where do you get
your peace from I said you're looking for peace oh she said badly she said I've no peace of
mind at all and so the conversation started there and I helped her but this is what Jesus
is saying that this interior piece actually draws souls so I said to her why did you come
in she said I was walking past the church she said I'm not really a church gore and she
said I felt drawn to come in and you were the only person here she said that's what Jesus
is saying here and so the more of this peace we have the more we hand over to the divine
will the more the Lord will draw souls to us not because we're great but because he has
an opportunity to have his throne on the earth so he said let me go back to the beginning
of that sentence don't you know the pieces the smile of the soul is the azure and serene
sky in which the divine sun makes its light blaze more vividly in such a way as to let
no cloud arise now this cloud is different to the last one that we've been speaking about
the last one was the cloud of light this time it's a cloud blocking light it's a problem
on our side and so it will let no cloud arise on the horizon which might occupy the light
and otherwise you don't let something in to block this divine light getting through so
peace is the beneficial Jew which vivifies everything it be jewels the soul my goodness
look at that for an expression it be jewels the soul with an unwrapturing beauty and it
attracts the continuous kiss of my will upon her now this word kiss is used frequently
actually is talking about bringing two things together the union okay so it attracts the
union of the divine will with the soul so the peace is one of the great ways we have
of drawing the divine will into us more and more and besides what is it that opposes the
truth where is this exalting you too much and I love the answer he gives only because
I told you that I placed you near my divine mother because she having been the depository
of all the goods of my redemption as my mother as virgin as queen I placed her at the head
of my redeemed ones giving her a distinct unique and special mission which nobody else
will be given the very apostles and the whole church depend on her and receive from her because
she's the mediatrix of all races so there's no good in which she does not possess all goods
come from her so I want to give you john 19 verses 26 and 27 when she where she was officially
constituted the mother of the body of Christ the mother of the church it was right that
as my mother I was to entrust everything and everyone to her maternal heart this is very
important when we're talking to one another that if a person feels they haven't got a devotion
whatever that is to marry that doesn't change the fact that you're her child and that she
has this extraordinary love for you and intercedes for you and we'll do anything for you embracing
everything being able to give everything to everyone was only for my mother so what jesus
is doing here is is now clarifying the mission of his mother on repeatable okay and then he's
going to place the mission of louisa beside that now I repeat to you that just as I placed
my mother at the head of all and I deposited it in her all the goods of redemption so I
chose another virgin whom I placed near her now notice the word near giving her the mission
of making my divine will known now he's going to explain that if you're given an office by
god that you have to have all the graces and everything that goes with that office so he's
going to tell us that now in a few minutes so blessed mother had everything she needed
for her office and now he's going to explain that louisa has to have everything for the
office that's been given to her as well so I chose another virgin whom I placed near
our blessed mother giving her the mission of giving her the mission of making my divine
will known and if redemption is great my will is even greater and just as for redemption
there was a beginning in time but not in eternity because god is immutable and all god's decisions
are eternal decisions so it's just we on earth have a beginning for the thing in the same
way for my divine will though it is eternal there was to be a beginning in time of it's
making itself known so this beginning in time for redemption and for opening up the kingdom
of the divine will is god's kyados time k-a-i-r-o-s if you want phonetics and it's a Greek word
meaning at the time for god's intervention in human history we usually operate on kranos
time from which you get the English word chronology so you have to have morning before evening
and Monday before Friday god doesn't follow chronology he follows kyados time therefore
jesus said because my will exists in heaven and on earth you see he could become incarnate
because his divine will existed on earth in his mother he can bring the kingdom of the
divine will on earth because it's now residing in louisa he can return in glory depending
on how many of us will allow the divine will to reside in us because we form the red carpet
of his return therefore because my will exists in heaven and on earth I was to choose a creature
to whom I was to entrust the deposit of the knowledge about the divine will now in case
you meet anybody who disputes that I want to give you Romans 9 15 to 18 where Paul says
that the potter doesn't have to ask the clay what would you like to be the potter decides
what the clay is to be and the clay cannot say to the potter I wanted to be a jug I didn't
want to be a cup and it's when you use the image of the potter and the clay you see that
some of our arguments are actually ludicrous so louisa is the one to whom he was to deposit
the knowledge of the divine will making known to her as to a second mother because he asked
her in volume two if she would be a second mother for him on the earth the first one
allowed him to bring the kingdom of redemption the second one allows him to bring the kingdom
of the divine will so so I was to make known to her the qualities and the value and the
prerogatives of the divine will so that she might love it and jealously keep it in deposit
the deposit on it and just as my celestial mother the true depository of the goods of
redemption that she is generous with whoever wants them so will the second mother be generous
in making known to all the deposit of my teachings the sanctity of it and the good that the divine
will wants to give how the divine will lives unknown in the midst of creatures now that
piece there it has been said before but the Lord is beginning to emphasize it more that
the divine will actually lives on the earth because nothing would exist without it if
the divine will is not in plants and animals they just simply disintegrate if the divine
will is not in the earth it just simply disintegrates he has to create and he has to maintain
in as well but the sadness that human beings have given to God is that God has to live
among us hidden and unknown I think you know if you get a chance to think about this later
Jesus has left himself to us in the Holy Eucharist but he's also hidden and unknown to the vast
majority of the human race it's it's incredible that God has to do that so we give him an amazing
sorrow how the divine will lives unknown in the midst of creatures and how from the beginning
of creation of man the divine will yearns and praise and supplicates that man would return
to his origin which is in the divine will now one of the amazing things that I think only
contemplation can help you with I don't think any anybody's words of explanation can help
and certainly I don't feel I can help you with it and that is to to look at the the enormity
of the humility of God who stays with us when we kick him in the teeth when we reject him
we throw him off the plan that we say terrible things about God we mean the human race not
you and me and we do all these terrible things and he stays his love is inexplicable his
love is so humble it would have been so easy for him to wipe out the human race and just
create another one much more compliant than we are he doesn't do that he behaves like
the father of the prodigal son who waits and waits and waits for the son to return so we
said my divine will even though it lives unknown in the midst of everybody it yearns it prays
it supplicates that man will return to his origin that is into my will in other words
God made us for eternal happiness with him in heaven and he is not giving up I find that
absolutely fantastic no matter how many blocks we put in the way he doesn't give up he doesn't
give up he doesn't give up he perseveres he perseveres he'll get through in the end it's
absolutely amazing so what we have to do is go back into our origin that is to the point
before we fell and into the divine will and that the rights of the divine will and its
sovereignty over creatures be restored so my redemption he said was one mission and I
made use of my dear mother in order to carry it out my divine will is also one mission and
I want to make use of another creature and placing her as though at the head now notice
he's been very careful because these priests who are objecting will object again so he
just says as though at the head and forming the deposit in her she was to serve me to
make my teachings known and to fulfill the designs of my divine will my dear friends that
is your mission and mine as well we have to take this into ourselves let him deposit
his divine will in us give us the knowledge and the understanding by reading and learning
and praying this wonderful message and then taking it out to others making it known to
others we can't keep it for ourselves we can't put this lamp on the rubbish we have to tell
others we have to become missionaries of the divine will so where is this exalting you
too much Jesus said who can deny that the redemption and the fulfillment of my will are too unique
but similar missions such that as they hold each other's hand this the kiss again that
there are actually two parts of one great plan so as they hold each other's hands my
will I will make the fruits of redemption be completed in the divine will and the rights
of redemption will be given back to us placing the seal on the purpose for which everything
was created so redemption had to come first because the human race had to be cleaned up
it had to be purified it had to be given the means to begin the spiritual journey to come
back to God and all of that had to happen before the divine will and all its fullness
could be revealed because the human race wouldn't have been able for it would have been able
to take it and so first things had to come first so this is why the knowledge of the
mission of our will interests us so much because nothing else will do so much good on the earth
to human beings please color that if you're looking at your book nothing else will do
so much good and you know from all the the prayers that we pray in the divine will that
the divine will gives us access to the intellects memories and wills and hearts of the human
race where we can influence them where the decisions are made you're no longer in the
position as you were in redemption of having to give them long speeches and long arguments
no you do the intercession from within in the divine will so there's nothing else will
do so much good to creatures as the divine will it will be the fulfillment and the crowning
of all of our works now he has to convince these priests who are having difficulty and
you know I simply sympathize absolutely with these priests they've never come across a
message like this before we've they've never come across a soul who is being led in this
particular way and they're having to be very brave to try and match up to it it's it's
really we need to sympathize with them I think so what he does then is that he goes back
into the Old Testament into the Hebrew Scriptures is the correct term and he gives an example
and then he comes at the time of the church and he gives examples in the church and he
could have given a string of examples in between but he just takes one or two and says look
this has happened before he said look go back to the time of King David that's a thousand
years before Christ it was said that he was an image of May now that's the first book of
Samuel chapter 13 and verse 14 and the words are here is a man after my own heart okay
so it was said that he was an image of me so much so that all of his sams reveal my
person not going there because all of the sams not only reveal the person and mission
of Christ but also his prayers and his intercession and everything if you've never come across
anybody explaining it to you then I have a set of CDs four CDs Christ and the sams and
illuminated for you so I'm sparing myself at this moment all of his sams he said reveal
me so there was something about David that was really like Christ now we know he was a
very faulty man and everything but there was something about him because otherwise he'd
never have been able to let the Holy Spirit reveal the Christ through his sams so now the
second example he gives is he jumps to the 11th century of the church to St Francis of
Assisi who was a faithful copy of me now that I actually enough I don't remember the pope
who canonized him but whoever he was said that Francis was a faithful copy of Christ
now he doesn't give a third example but I'm going to give you a third example and that's
a little lady at the end of the 19th century trace of Lisieux because the pope who canonized
her said that she was a miniature of Christ in other words all the parts were there it
was just a tiny picture and so Jesus is saying you know what's your problem it said in the
holy gospel he said this is Matthew 548 you are to be perfect as your heavenly father
is perfect no less so there's the heavenly father as your model what are you having a
problem with Mary being your model you are to be perfect as your heavenly father is perfect
no less it's also added that no one will even enter the kingdom of God of heaven of heaven
tells you it's Matthew's gospel of course of God will tell you it's it's Mark and Luke
and no one will enter the kingdom of heaven if he's not similar to the image of the son
of God so I want to give you Matthew 19 21 and Matthew 25 31 to 46 and the reason why
I gave you Matthew 25 it's the final judgment and you know that if you look at Jesus in
the gospel he was reaching out to the poor and the needy and looking after the sick and
everybody who was in great need and the judgment actually given in Matthew 25 is did you look
after the poor and the needy very interesting will you like me and then he says and there
are many other things as well all of these he said no one says that they've been exalted
to him much and they be compared to Jesus himself or God the father and that these are
things not conforming to truth spoken by my very mouth he said you can't say they're
not they're in the gospels so only because of you that's Louisa I said that I wanted
to compare you to the virgin so that you would be her faithful copy now look what Jesus is
doing he's saying that all of us are to be like the heavenly father which seems an impossibility
and he said Louisa I said you were to be like my mother she's a human being no matter how
exalted she is she's a human being so why do they say that it's too much he said I've
exalted you too much so he said comparing those to me was not exalting them nor did
anyone raise any doubt or difficulty but then comparing to the virgin that's too much notice
he's comparing God with the human beings this means that they've not understood well the
mission of the knowledge of my will notice it's a mission I've been emphasizing that for
quite some time for you this is not just a spirituality this is not just a way of praying
this is actually a mission indeed I repeat to you that I not only place you near her as
her little daughter on her maternal lap now you remember this message start the last message
started with Louisa on Jesus's lap so I place you on her maternal lap that she may guide
you and instruct you on how you must imitate her to become her faithful copy by always doing
the divine will now there you have a little summary of the blessed virgin in the divine
will for the month of May little summary all in one sentence but he said I do this so that
from her lap you may pass to the lap of the divinity that's where we're called in fact
the mission of my will is eternal because God is immutable he doesn't change whatever
he wants he wants eternally and it is precisely the mission of our celestial father who wants
who commands who expects nothing else but his will to be known and loved that it be done
on earth as it is in heaven Matthew 6 10 now that's the statement that Jesus there made
is that the holy father once commands expects nothing but his will to be done excuse me you
read John's gospel a summary of John's gospel is I only do what my father tells me to do
I only say what my father tells me to say the father and I are one always do what pleases
the father and he goes on and on and on and he finishes with the incredible thing in John
14 31 I want the world to know that I love the father and therefore I do exactly what
my father tells me it's all about doing the will of God but if you've studied the Bible
I've taken a group of people now from Genesis and now as revelation we haven't with some
of them I've taken the most of the way the entire issue in the Bible is simply doing the
will of God nothing else because if human beings will do the will of God he'll brings
the kingdom of God on earth and he finds a way to save everybody so God is immutable
he hasn't changed and so when we are trying to live this obedience and surrender and abandonment
to the divine will and we are obeying God in the Old Testament God the father we are obeying
God in the New Testament and we are obeying God the spirit God the father God the son
and God the Holy Spirit the divine will so you Jesus said to Louisa making this eternal
mission your own and imitating your celestial father you must want nothing else for yourself
and for all others now notice you see that in this mission this is love without borders
God is love without borders if he was to pick and choose who was fit for his love he'd have
practically nobody our love has to be without borders we don't ask what race what religion
or anything else and so it gets over all our prejudices it gets over all our blocks and
allows us to truly be an instrument of God for the human race so you making this eternal
mission your own and imitating the celestial father must want nothing else for yourself
and for all others but that the divine will be known loved and fulfilled and besides when
it is the creature who exalts herself we should think about it that's Matthew 23 12 whoever
exalts herself will be humbled and whoever humbles herself will be exalted Matthew said
himself but Jesus talking about Louisa so I'm saying herself so if you're exalting yourself
yeah worry about it but when the soul remains at her place of nothingness understood and
obedience and I exalt her everything is permissible to God it depends on who exalts her I make
one reach wherever I want and in the way I want and therefore he said trust me and don't
be concerned that is absolutely fantastic the Lord is saying don't let the concerns
of anybody else put you off from completing this wonderful mission in the divine will
and don't let yourself do it either because very often we are our own worst enemy so let's
come to April the 23rd 1925 and we're talking about again the importance of the acts now
don't forget how high Louisa is in this extraordinary union with God and she fuses herself all the
time that's why you and I have got to do it all the time I fuse all of me and all of
you all the time I was fusing myself in the holy divine volition according to my usual
way and my sweet Jesus making himself felt in my interior to the kingdom of God is there
he said my daughter come into the immensity of my will because we're entering into the
immensity of God in entering into his will all of heaven and all things created by me
live and receive continuous life by my will that's all things whether they're animate
or inanimate in which they find their complete glory their full happiness and their perfect
beauty and that is most particularly us the human creatures we find our complete glory
our full happiness our perfect beauty in the divine will so and they anxiously await the
kiss of the pilgrim soul that's the union of the pilgrim soul so everything that God
has created is anxiously waiting for the souls in the divine will that's Romans 819 that the
whole of creation is longing for these sons of God to show themselves so that the whole
of creation can be restored so heaven and all of creation is awaiting at the union of
the pilgrim soul who lives in the same divine will in which they live to requite her with
their kiss so everything will be in union we're in union with heaven we're in union
with earth we're in union with ourselves we're in union with each other they will requite
her with their kiss and to place in common with her the glory happiness and beauty which
they possess so that their number may be increased by another creature who would render
me complete glory for as much as it is possible for a creature now notice you're being told
that not only the dwellers of heaven but all of creation wants to celebrate your arrival
in the divine will another one is joining us so I want to give you juturonomy six verses
four to ten that the people who will arrive and swell this wonderful celestial company
on the earth first of all and then in heaven a living juturonomy six four to ten hero Israel
the lord your god is one lord and you shall love the lord your god with all your heart
with all your soul with all your mind and with all of your being notice the a double
L every time it's complete surrender so their number may be increased by another creature
who would render me complete glory for as much as is possible for a creature and would make
me look at the earth with the love with which I created it now we started off tonight with
louisa on jesus lap and then she experiencing this cloud of light and that it was through
this cloud of light which was the divine will resident in her that he was looking more mercifully
upon the earth and he's saying here he wants to do that with each one of us so we have
to allow this cloud of light to get as large as possible so that this will be accomplished
as he said on earth there is a creature who operates and lives in the divine will that
is the celebration of heaven since heaven knows that nothing glorifies me as much as a soul
who lives in my will they too long from my will to live with the souls of earth and he
wants they the dwellers of heaven also want god to have his throne on earth because when
god has his throne on earth then his kingdom will come and all his designs for the human
race will be accomplished so they want that very badly as well so don't forget that they
are all backing us up they're all praying for us they're all wanting each one of us
to succeed and they're all praying that we will abandon ourselves totally to the divine
will so Jesus said each act which the person does in my will is a kiss or an act of union
that she gives and receives from the one who created her it's an act of union this is
a kiss is an act of union and she receives it from all the blessed as well not just from
god himself but from all the the blessed this is for each act but do you know what this
kiss is it is the transformation of the soul with her creator so he's talking about how
we come to possess god and how he comes to possess us each act does it like each act
is like a stitch that's going to make up this beautiful jumper or cardigan and the cardigan
or jumper is not going to turn up until all the stitches are in place so I've got to knit
fast to try and get there it is the transformation of the soul with her creator it is the possession
of god in the soul that's heaven and it is the possession of the soul in god so god possesses
the soul the soul possesses god that's it your purpose on earth is achieved that's why
you're here as a pilgrim soul and it a person living at this level the lord can do his will
on earth as a stone in heaven it is the growth of the divine life in the soul it is the accord
of the whole of heaven the whole of heaven is is wanting this and is with you and it is
the right of supremacy over all created things that means genesis restored or the garden
of Eden restored or the pre fall condition of man restored when the rights of supremacy
overall creation are given back to us the soul purged by my will through that omnipotent
breath wow the holy spirit which was infused into her by god no longer produces the nausea
of the human will and therefore god continues look at the word continues that means every
moment of your life if you don't block it and god continues to breathe upon her with
his omnipotent breath you remember Jesus in john 20 20 I think it is where he the apostles
were still like the inert Adam unable to be church until he breathed the breath of god
into them and they became the living church afterwards so in this union that we have with
god in the divine will he continuously breathes upon us and therefore if the spirit is continuously
breathing upon us then we are being recreated and we are being brought to the fullness of
perfection as god wants what more would you want I can't imagine you wanting anything
after this that she may grow in that divine will in which god created her and then you
get there on the other hand this is how you know that Jesus is a Jew because their way
of arguing is to tell you what it is on this hand the right hand is the hand of power and
authority and grace and everything and then on the other hand you get the negative you
see you remember fiddler on the roof on the other hand the soul who has not yet been purged
feels the attraction of our own will now notice clearly that if we're to reach possession
of god that there's a ferocious purging that must take place and there's no way out of it
if you don't have this purging the draw back to the human will is very strong the draw back
to self will the draw back to selfishness the draw back to sin in other words you can
fall very fast the soul is not yet being purged feels the attraction of our own will and so
she acts against the will of god doing her own god cannot approach her to breathe upon
her again if you have your own book would you color that god can not approach her if
you're doing your own will he cannot accomplish his will in you it's as simple as that and
so I think as we become more and more aware of our thoughts and our feelings and our words
and our reactions and everything there must be a ferocious amount of repentance we're
repenting for this thought and that thought and the other thought to try and give the
Lord a chance and and the end you say look take over take over I won't be able to do
this so if we act against the will of god god cannot approach her to breathe upon her
again until that soul gives a double L all of herself to the exercise and the fulfillment
of the divine will so again I bring it to two things Hebrews 1214 nothing on holy or
unworthy can enter the presence of god it's actually that simple and the second one is
that without holiness no one will ever see god the other the second one I was going to
give you is just stick my mind at this particular moment and we have to yeah the second one is
that we it's all our decision we're the one who's been given free will and we are the ones
who decide yes I want to take this journey I want to reach its goal I know I'm this very
weak sinful human being but Lord you can accomplish this you are the one who can work
prejudice I handed over to you you're the divine artist Ephesians 210 we are God's
work of art so we we have to just hand it over and ask our blessed lady to take charge
of us as well so let's come to the next paragraph Jesus said to her you must know that in creating
man God infused life into him with his breath as Genesis 2 7 and it's only at that point
that were told that man became a living being he infused in him an intelligence a memory
and a will the three powers of the soul to place them in relationship with his divine
will now notice we've had this a few messages back all of these connect connecting wires
that he said between us and him and they every part of our body is part of this connecting
system with him he's going to give it give us a little revision of that and this divine
will was to be like a king because it was in this condition of the divine will raining
in man that man was a constituted king upon the earth when he rejected the divine will
he became a slave and this divine will was to be like a king who was to dominate the
whole interior of the human person now notice where God wants to be king he allowed man
to be king on the earth but God was to be king of us that the kingdom of God is within
you that's what Jesus said Luke 17 21 the kingdom of God is within you and everything
that's to be conquered is inside of us and if everything that's to be conquered is in
fact conquered then the world will surrender and this divine will was to be like a king
who was to dominate the whole interior of the human creature and to give life to everything
divine life in such a way as to form the intelligence and the memory wanted by the divine will
in her once this was formed it could be would be as though natural for the eye of the creature
to look at created things and to know their order and the will of God over the whole universe
or hearing was to hear the prejudice of the divine will or mouth was to feel itself breathed
upon continuously by its creator to communicate to it the life and the goods which the divine
will contains the mouth was to echo that divine fiat in its word Luke 138 fiat me he secondum
verbum to be done unto me according to your word we just simply say fiat okay now notice
the mouth was given to us so that we could express the fiat human beings seem to express
anything but the fiat the mouth was to echo that eternal fiat with its word and to narrate
what the will of God means now notice we're being told what to do with our eyes with our
mouth with our hearing with our intelligence everything our hands were to be the outpouring
of the works of the supreme will her feet were to do nothing but follow step by step the steps
of the creator so if we have to follow the creator and he's our model why would you complain
about blessed mother being a model so once the divine will is established in the will
of the creature she has the eye the hearing the mouth the hands and the feet on my will
God is able to rain on earth he's able to return he returns in each one of us she never
departs from her origin from which she came she remains always in my arms so this is a
permanent union and it's easier for her to feel my breath now you've heard you've heard
Jesus say to Louisa in this recent message but don't you feel me inside of you he's been
saying that to her a lot in in volume 17 I'm not just there theoretically surely you feel
me there and then she admits that she does so he's saying that this is our call okay
then we would actually be able to sense the breath of the Holy Spirit in us now if you
want to get a sense or a feel for that go to the early chapters of the acts of the apostles
where it's very very clear that the apostles and the earliest Christians definitely felt
the Holy Spirit and the push of the Holy Spirit and the inspiration of the spirit and
the power of the spirit and the guidance of the spirit and did the works of God these
people who were so frail before the coming of the spirit were so incredibly powerful
and fruitful afterwards so it would be easier for the soul to feel my breath and for me
to breathe upon her now this is precisely what I want from all of you okay that the soul
will let my will reign in her and that her will may serve as a dwelling place for me with
one Corinthians 3 16 to let the divine will deposit the celestial goods it contains so
here's the Lord pleading with each one of us it's okay what he's doing with Louisa and
what he's done with blessed mother and all the rest of it but now it's our turn and he's
asking us to really allow this to happen in us and this is what I want from you he said
so that all your acts marked by my will now those of you who are interested in the mark
of the beast notice this all your acts marked with the divine will means that the mark of
heaven is on everything you'll form one single act and uniting to the single act of my will
which has no multiplicity of acts because God is a singularity there's neither past nor
future everything is present in that tiny tiny point that's why we can pray for past
present and future because it's all present in the divine will uniting to the single act
of my will which has no multiplicity of acts as in man they may remain in that eternal beginning
in order to copy your creator and to give him the glory and the contentment that his will
is done in you as it is in heaven now that's a perfect description of our calling into this
mission of the divine will and because it's a natural place to stop and go to stop there
tonight I'll just finish by saying a little prayer holy father at the end of this day
and at the end of these reflections on your divine will we come before your supreme majesty
to offer you from the depths of our hearts our adoration homage praise and thanksgiving
in the name of all and to do this we fuse all of ourselves in your most holy divine will
we take your power your wisdom and love to ourselves so that we can pray to you with
all your own things and at your own divine level since your power wisdom and love are
in communication with the three powers of the soul you will feel our adoration homage praise
and thanksgiving flow within the intellect memory and will of all your children past
present and future and then rising between heaven and earth you will hear the echo of
your own power wisdom and love worshiping you divinely how wonderful for us father to
be part of the glory and praise of the august divine persons themselves we bring all souls
before you in adoration and praise and begin now a peon of praise to our god and father
that will continue on earth to the end and forever in heaven amen.